[музика]
через брак спеціалістів в офісі
президента які змогли б вирішити цю
завдання та провести аудит бюджетних витрат
є необхідність звернутися саме до
вам дорогий глядач саме до тебе
найрозумніший розумієшся на математиці
допоможи вирішити просте завдання бюджет за
квітень офісу президента 500 мільйонів з
на них витрати витратили 200 мільйонів на
видосики та зеленого щодня та
обертання фільм рік президента та ленського
і так далі відповідно залишилося 300
мільйонів 150 мільйонів витратили на
ботів які пишуть коментарі facebook
instagram youtube ну ви знаєте їх
Микола Микола Ольга Ольга
пишуть з помилками і так далі
150 мільйонів 90 мільйонів витратили на
кортеж ви всі бачили сорок дві машини
сорок два автомобілі що прибувають
вулицями києва залишилося 60 мільйонів 60
мільйонів витратили на оплату рахунків з
де сторони велюр
відповідно ось усі витрати 200 150
9060 500 мільйонів рахуємо у цій
колоночки 300 мільйонів плюс 150
мільйонів плюс 60 вийшло 500 10
мільйонів уваги питання хто вкрав 10
мільйонів відповіді пишіть у коментарі до
цьому відео
[музика]